good morning john sometimes i worry a
little bit about how central social
media has become
in my life like you watch bo burnham's
inside and you think to yourself well
that
doesn't all seem great and then you look
over at loneliness and isolation and
mental health problems and it does seem
a little bit correlated
if not causative and then over there you
have the erosion of shared truth and
discourse and it does seem like the
radical decentralization of information
sharing and gathering
has played a part in that but then like
also i do like it
and i am good at it and i've been doing
it for a very long time and it is fun on
an average day i'm really grateful to
have the job that i have
creating things on the internet
basically what i'm saying is that i
would hate to hate it because i
do like it now there are things that i
hate to hate but i should hate like
eating hamburgers like i hate to hate a
hamburger because ultimately i do love
them but they are bad for pretty much
everyone involved the question is
is the internet like a cow and i don't
think it is i think that not having cows
anymore
if it just happened would probably be
for the best whereas i think
if the internet just vanished one day
that that would be worse i've been
thinking about it like
i'm on twitter and there are times when
twitter does not make me happy
but there are also times when it does
make me happy so here are the choices
that are generally presented to me
you can stay on twitter or you can leave
twitter i don't like that choice i think
there is a third choice which is to use
twitter the way that you wish other
people used it
and never don't do that it's hard
it's hard but it's possible since you
know i don't know like around january of
this year
i have started to be able to use twitter
in a way that i i actually quite enjoy
just trying to make jokes talk about
things that i love talk about my life a
little bit and
maybe maybe inspire and participate in
discussion
that is productive around things that
are not as hot as the center of the sun
which is hard because it seems like
either the culture or structure of
twitter does
want to draw you into whatever the
hottest thing is that day two days ago
lindsey graham tweeted that he would go
to war for the values that chick-fil-a
stands for which is a tweet that like
couldn't be
more well designed to create screaming
so much so
that it becomes clear upon reflection
that that's the goal
and i did i began to compose a tweet
about the absurdity of a
u.s senator proposing that he would go
to war for a fast food restaurant during
a global pandemic and then i
snapped back into my brain and i deleted
it because this
is the exact thing that twitter is worst
at and the only thing that paying
attention to a controversy like that
does is lend power to the divisive
politician
who's trying to chip different parts of
humanity into pieces
so that he can create more engaged anger
stands i think it's very easy to look at
any
large complicated system and notice only
the problems and say we should throw
that away but that's not what happens
because usually one you can't like it's
not possible but what it ignores is that
the intellectually
simple thing is to just like carve that
out and say that shouldn't exist
whereas the complicated hard thing that
we're not going to have great answers to
it's going to take a long time
is to say what actions make this better
not
how do we stop doing this but how do we
do it differently not
how do i not eat hamburgers anymore how
do i make a hamburger without a cap
massive scale many to many communication
is brand new it did not exist when i was
born
we are bad at it we because we are new
to it i think it causes a lot of
disruption and division and confusion
and suffering but
problems don't get fixed by ignoring
them and i love the internet and i still
believe in the promise of the internet
even if it is more delayed than i
assumed that it would be in short i just
think that that promise is something we
should continue to think about and fight
for
john i'll see you on tuesday and
speaking of thinking about the internet
too much
i have written two novels that tell one
story the first one to me is a story
within the frame of like what the
internet is like right now whereas the
second one
is more about what the internet might be
like in the future and as of this week
they are both available in paperback so
if you've been biding your time the
prices are now right and they are
available wherever books are sold